inclusión hablamos mucho de ella pero no
siempre sabemos lo que significa salvo
que la palabra es sinónimo de inserción
de integración en el mundo de la moda en
el que no se puede dejar de navegar por
los fenómenos sociales están surgiendo
iniciativas llamativas un ejemplo hay
muchos y como verán en muchos ámbitos
empecemos por las excluidas las que
luchan por encontrar su lugar en la
sociedad a causa de su discapacidad un
accidente una enfermedad y una
amputación y no es fácil enfrentarse al
tema
y sigue siendo un tabú en mi opinión es
obvio por varias razones la primera de
las cuales es que de hecho hay una
aprensión en la relación con la persona
discapacitada y luego hay una
superstición cuanto menos hablemos de
ello cuanto menos sepamos menos
probabilidades tendremos de que nos
afecten excepto que la discapacidad nos
afecta a todos en algún momento y si no
es inmediatamente entonces a través de
la vejez la mayoría de nosotros están
afectados
el hotel des invalides construido bajo
el reinado de luis 14 sigue siendo un
hospital que atiende tanto a militares
como a civiles un lugar legítimo para
acoger el desfile evento organizado por
la asociación fénix que lucha por la
aceptación de las diferencias
para mí nunca ha sido un tabú porque es
una decisión personal se debe a mi
historia cáncer de huesos recaída dolor
metástasis dolor de huesos así que de
hecho no había nada más que hacer me
amputaron y desde entonces vivo feliz
sin embargo la mayoría ha perdido algo
bueno la similitud la cidh ix feminidad
seducción moda cuando uno lleva prótesis
como lo vive en su vida diaria
a veces es complicado y al mismo tiempo
es una lucha diaria para mantener la
propia feminidad y la autoestima
que significa seguir siendo femenina
que te miren como una mujer no que te
vean como discapacitada sino ser vista
como una mujer no soy discapacitada que
soy mujer
a veces es el azar el que lleva a la
inclusión un día en 2005 en parís un
antropólogo se encontró con decenas de
inmigrantes en la calle después de
investigar se dio cuenta de que los
extranjeros que reciben sus papeles no
serán contratados por las
cualificaciones que han adquirido en su
país sino enviados en masa a sectores
con mano de obra insuficiente como el
sector de la construcción entonces
decide crear la organización la fábrica
a nómada para seleccionar a los que
tienen conocimientos de moda en sus
países tenían estas habilidades estas
profesiones pero se practican de una
manera completamente diferente con
métodos y organizaciones completamente
diferentes por lo que necesitan ser
apoyados en este aumento de las
habilidades para que puedan satisfacer
las necesidades del mercado la
colaboración entre la fábrica normal la
empresa de slip fences y la diseñadora
áñez be nació para una colección de
pañuelos y delantales de cocina cuyos
beneficios se dedicarán íntegramente a
la formación de los inmigrantes
el sector textil se enfrenta a un
verdadero reto de formación y
contratación los talleres hoy en día
tienen muchas exigencias los grandes
almacenes todos nosotros como clientes
las marcas vemos que todo el mundo
quiere fabricar localmente excepto que
no existen las capacidades así que era
muy natural proponer a las personas que
tienen esta formación este saber hacer
aquí acompañarlos para integrarlas a los
talleres textiles en los que trabajamos
todos los días y que tienen este
verdadero tema de formación internamente
para responder a la demanda de
fabricación francesa
cuando había este proyecto con la
fábrica nómada me uní inmediatamente
porque es exactamente lo que me interesa
creo que en el mundo hay talentos por
todas partes creo que los hombres que
las mujeres todavía necesitan expresarse
a través de su cultura de sus
tradiciones de su saber hacer tenemos un
know-how francés nos encanta la ropa nos
encantan las telas nos encanta crear
también nos encanta hacer gafas o
zapatos bolsos corbatas dejaremos
hacerlo todo en francés
se llama victoria y tomás como pareja en
la ciudad y en el escenario abogan por
la corresponsabilidad el intercambio y
el compartir la decoración la música los
grabados fueron diseñados en
colaboración con artistas
[Música]
después tenemos un casting especial para
nosotros es muy personal
de hecho esta temporada tenemos a
nuestras dos madres desfilando queríamos
un poco de diversidad en el reparto pero
una diversidad natural
y para nosotros era muy obvio que
nuestras madres llevan muchas de
nuestras piezas en la vida real y
queríamos que lo mostraran en la
pasarela diferentes edades diferentes
cuerpos siempre parece como si nuestra
ropa no es solo para los modelos es ropa
de verdad la abuela de tomás también
lleva nuestra ropa desgraciadamente no
ha podido venir hoy pero es para todos
cómo se siente llevando la ropa diseñada
por su hija
hay un poste
al principio no podía ponerme las tallas
xs que hacía pero últimamente hacen las
tallas grandes y me queda perfecto
me encanta y me queda perfecto
me parece bien me siento bien llevando
los puestos y
me imagino que está orgullosa
por supuesto que estoy orgullosa de mi
hijo y de victoria son un verdadero
equipo y es importante que los apoye
como modelo y como madre mount
puede que estas últimas opiniones no
sean del todo objetivas pero en
cualquier caso se trata de otra faceta
de la información
[Música]